why use gpus in neural networks
there is a hardware and a software
aspect to this answer
and so this is going to be a two-part
series in this video we're going to take
a look at what the gpu hardware provides
that makes neural net training much
faster and in the next video what
software and algorithm changes do gpus
make to speed up gpu processing
what is 5 times six times seven
two hundred and ten two hundred and ten
what is eight times three times five one
twenty one twenty
what is seven times twelve times three
two fifty two two fifty two the cpu is
blazing fast the gpu is almost as fast
but slightly trails behind
what is matrix a times matrix b
this
cpu your answer
this
looks like the cpu took its own sweet
time
gpus are used in neural nets because of
this ability to perform matrix
multiplication so fast
but why does this happen
why are cpus great with scalar
multiplications and gpus better with
matrix multiplications
three main reasons
gpus have a larger memory bandwidth they
use parallelization
and they have faster and more memory
access than cpus
we're going to delve into these three
points in detail and then show some pie
torch code in action that really
demonstrates the difference in speed
let's get started
so here's a block diagram we have a
system memory this is the main memory
which contains the matrices that we need
to multiply
we have a cpu and a gpu
and each of these also have their own
memory that i'll just label as
memory without the details for now
let's make an analogy here the cpu is a
ferrari and the gpu is a truck
case one performing scalar
multiplication
the cpu can get this data with a fetch
operation to memory the amount of data
that we can fetch though is pretty tiny
but it's large enough to fetch floating
point numbers within a couple of trips
and these fetches happen blazing fast
like a ferrari
a gpus fetch operation on the other hand
can transmit a lot more data but they
are not optimized for speed
so they're like a truck
they can take more time to fetch and
process small chunks of data
and that's why for scalar
multiplications gpus can lag behind cpus
case two when we multiply two large
matrices
cpu it has a super fast fetch operation
but each fetch can only transmit a tiny
amount of data to and from memory
so it can take thousands of trips to
fetch all the required data
while one trip is being fetched the cpu
memory is processed and freed up for the
next inputs
this is where gpus work much better
at a time we can fetch much larger
amounts of data from the ram into the
gpu's memory so the gpu doesn't need to
make that many trips
in more technical terms gpus have a
higher memory bandwidth than cpus
memory bandwidth is the amount of data
that can be transmitted in a single trip
to and from the memory
and this is one of the main reasons gpus
have an edge over the cpus for large
matrix multiplication
but even if we get a lot of packages or
a lot of data
the gpu processors remain idle for a
while
after all they're too fast and the truck
is just too slow so instead of having a
single truck we can have a fleet of
trucks
this way gpu processors do not need to
wait around and it always has data to
work with
this notion of using a fleet of trucks
is called parallelization
coupling large memory bandwidth with
parallelization reduces any time a gpu
would be waiting
so basically we fetch a lot of data and
we do it fast
but gpus offer something more
faster memory
i used the term memory very vaguely
before but what i'm really talking about
are the caches and the registers
gpus have a similar structure but gpus
l1 and l2 caches are smaller in size
than a cpus l1 and l2 caches
smaller size means that it can be
accessed much faster
and also these streamlined processors of
a gpu have a bunch of registers which
are super fast
and gpus have upwards of a thousand
times more registers to play around with
than cpus
so all of these memory enhancements
together makes computations just blazing
fast
and it's a combination of these three
points that gpus are faster than cpus
for matrix multiplication
especially for large matrices
faster multiplication means that we can
perform operations in deep learning also
faster
cool
but how do we actually make use of gpus
as a programmer well this is where cuda
comes in
from a programmer's view cuda provides
an api that allows us to access the
components of a gpu like the streamlined
processors the caches and the registers
cuda already provides a nice high level
abstraction but deep learning frameworks
like pi torch make life even easier we
don't even need to know about the inner
components of a gpu we just treat it as
one big abstract unit called a gpu and
we're all good to go
let's actually see how matrix
multiplication with gpus perform
i'm in google collab and it's an
environment that allows you to run your
code in chunks and see the outputs
directly
i have some code cells here that we can
walk through
the first cell is a scalar
multiplication with the cpu
we're just taking the square of a number
pi torch uses tensors as the fundamental
building blocks and you can think of
tensors as wrappers around your scalers
and matrices for any dimension
i'm just squaring a one cross one tensor
here
we're using a command called time it to
calculate the execution time of this
block of code
these are known as magic functions if
you want to look them up for more
reference
looks like the cpu took 5.26
microseconds to do this
that's super fast
in the second cell we have similar code
but this time we multiply a ten thousand
by ten thousand matrix
with itself
and this took 11.8 seconds
it probably seems like it it's taking
longer when you actually run it but
that's only because it's being executed
three times
for the rest of the code you need to set
up a gpu
so for this you gotta go to the menu bar
and click on runtime
then on the drop down you go to change
runtime type
and from the hardware accelerator
drop-down select gpu
this initializes the gpu
we now have to tell pi torch to use this
gpu
and we use torch.device to get a
reference to this gpu
and this dot 2 device
tells pytorch to store and process this
variable z using the gpu
let's run the cell
okay so that took 35.2 microseconds
which was slower than the 5.26
microseconds that we did using without
the gpu
so it was slower
let's now run the large matrix
multiplication with the gpu
okay wow that took less than a second
way faster than the 12 seconds it took
before
pretty slick right so how exactly does
gpu speed up matrix
multiplication on the hardware side gpus
have three main advantages over cpus
the first is high memory bandwidth
that is the amount of data that can be
transferred to and from memory
gpus have a high memory bandwidth they
can transmit large chunks of a matrix
between different gpu parts
in the last video we saw this by
comparing a cpu to a small yet fast
ferrari and a gpu to a slow but a very
high capacity truck
the second advantage that gpus offer is
parallelization
which means that we can transmit large
matrix chunks in parallel
this is equivalent to using a fleet of
trucks
while the gpu is processing the current
matrix chunks it is fetching more chunks
from the system memory so the gpu is
never idle
the third advantage of gpus is fast
memory access gpus have small registers
and caches but there's a bunch of them
we can store a lot of data and access it
pretty fast
a gpu has a few streamlined
multiprocessors these constitute the
processing part of the gpu
it has a global memory that is shared by
these multiprocessors
and some local memory that is specific
to the multiprocessors and cannot be
shared with other
sms this hardware has so much potential
but it is pointless if we don't use it
in a clever way
we're going to look at what algorithms a
gpu uses for multiplying large matrices
so that it makes use of this hardware to
its fullest
let's start with a quick review of
matrix multiplication
if you want to multiply matrices a and b
the number of columns in a should be the
same as the number of rows in b
the output product will have the same
number of rows as a
and it'll have the same number of
columns as b
the first element is computed by taking
the first row of matrix a
and the first column of matrix b
then we take the element wise product
and sum that up
the element in the first row and second
column is computed by taking the first
row of a and the second column of b
take the element wise product and sum
that up
similarly we compute the other elements
this is how we would do it by hand
but what if we were dealing with
multiplying two matrices that were of
ten thousand cross ten thousand in
dimension
how would a computer do this and how
would it do it efficiently
well the first case is using brute force
we multiply every pair of numbers one at
a time and sum that up as we would by
hand
but the problem with this approach is
that it takes way too long
gpus take time to fetch data and we
aren't making use of its high bandwidth
and parallelization if we process one
element at a time
so that brings us to the second case
we can use the gpu memory which is
shared by the streamlined
multiprocessors
the gpu memory may not be large enough
to hold both large matrices
but it could be large enough to hold the
i throw of matrix a and the jth column
of matrix b
we could fetch these into the gpu memory
and this way we use more bandwidth we
use some amount of parallelization to
fetch the data and processing here is
faster than in the first case with brute
force since now we're using the gpu
memory
but we can do this even faster using
block multiplication
instead of using the gpu memory we can
make use of the shared memory within a
streamlined multiprocessor
this means that each sm would compute a
block of the final matrix
but we can only allocate a block to an
sm if every element in this submatrix
block can be computed using the same
shared data
and
it should be small enough to fit in
the sm memory
this is possible with block
multiplication
so first let's talk about the math
behind block multiplication
we want to multiply two four cross four
matrices
we can split the matrix into blocks of
say 2 cross 2.
the final product can be written as a
product of these elements
i know it looks messy but the main
takeaway is that to compute all the
elements in a 2 cross 2 block of the
result that is like c11 for example we
would need to take the sum of products
of blocks in the original matrices
this result is handy because of the
small memory constraints of the
multiprocessors
one sm is responsible for computing the
block elements of c11
we can take the sub matrix blocks a11
and b11 to compute the intermediate sum
we remove the blocks from memory and
then we take a12 and b21 into the memory
take their product add it to the
intermediate sum and then we get the
full matrix c11
and while we can compute this sub matrix
block c11 in parallel the other sms
would have computed different blocks in
the final matrix
this is much faster since we're using
the memory within a streamlined
multiprocessor
we can make use of more memory bandwidth
to fetch the blocks of data
either into the gpu or into the
streamline processor memory
and lots of parallelization is going on
from getting data from the system memory
and also in parallel processing with the
streamlined multiprocessors
but clearly to make block multiplication
work there are a few hyper parameters we
would need to know to get it working we
would need to determine the optimal
block size and also the number of
streamlined multiprocessors to use and
not to mention how do we also allocate
which blocks go to which streamline
multiprocessor well cuda takes care of
determining all of this under the hood
and all we need to do is tell our system
to use a gpu with a single line of code
and that's it i hope this video was
interesting there are some interesting
pieces of research on further algorithm
speedups that i'll reference in the
description down below
but that's all for now
i hope you guys enjoyed this please like
and subscribe for more content on
machine learning deep learning and data
sciences and i will see you in the next
one
bye bye